I like to start things just with an
entertaining a little story about
something that might be familiar
familiar with all of you guys so this is
a slightly exaggerated story of a death
or life on the death so the lead
developer says basically hey boss we've
got this application it's a 1.0 the
client loves it let's just send it out
let's put it in the world let's get it
working the manager says let me check
with everyone in the company and because
that's how it works and then I'll get
back to you and we'll deploy if it's
ready so that all hands me the next day
the CTO says this huge speech this very
busy buzz wordy speech about how we're
going to change the world with it and he
says let's launch it and Lee developer
goes to the keyboard tights his commands
and because we're hooked into something
like Heroku he can push to github you
know ironically deploy so we do that
slack bought cheers everything is good
so six months later we begin to work
that morning and we learned that from
New York Times that there's been a
massive leak of credit card info all
kinds of information and passwords that
were poorly hash or not hashed at all
slack life has also been taken over and
we have to send bitcoins to get our BOTS
back and of course it's also your name
so people that went to the Sakai talks
those are awesome just beware your stock
pot is not off-limits to hackers and
what happens we all freak out the
world's ending people are losing their
money and then you just feel like this
so we're gonna go through some baby
steps and teach you first we're going to
talk about how security works why it
matters how to think like an attacker
and then we're gonna get into some
really in-depth stuff in JavaScript and
what you can build into your
applications to make them work better
work better in the sense that they'll be
secure I'm doing really good in time so
maybe slow down a bit so the first step
is to understand the problem this is a
picture from just the other day updated
from information as beautiful net of the
world's biggest data breaches you can
see some of these on here Yahoo that was
on here I mean LinkedIn is somewhere and
it's like miniscule here on eBay
Home Depot when you heard about the
credit card information Friend Finder is
more recent in MySpace
all kinds of stuff here it's really a
problem and these breaches cost millions
of dollars I and even more on top of
that incident response a survey was done
by IBM and this kind of concerns
esophageal courage and just making up
stats in certain response costs four
million dollars per breach on average
among a 380 global companies they
surveyed so security doesn't exactly
provide money directly it's not like if
I you know put some nice headers in my
application that protect against bad
scripts that doesn't give your company
the money that it wants right then what
it does is down the road it saves you
potentially millions of dollars in
damage reputation my customers Incident
Response advanced solutions that you
have had to deploy people to hire it
saves you money in the long run and
that's why a lot of people put it off to
the side because they don't see the
drunk value and at the time so we have a
lot of our abilities like I said it's
hard heartbleed 2014 it was living in
the open SSL codebase from 2011 it was
discovered in 2014 for three years
anyone has a server in here that was
deployed on any saw any hosting service
AWS digitalocean
I mean Bluehost who knows you could just
arbitrarily read data off this server so
I could send one command to your server
and get all of the keys off your server
your private keys all of that and who
knows how much that was exploited I mean
I'm sure
government agencies around the world
voiding it because they probably knew
about it on hackers whatever and they
just found it 2014 and they made all
these pretty logos in which like oh cool
we ought to do with that again but
turned out others shell-shocked was a
bash bug poodle was a SSL degradation
SSL HTTPS we could basically say you are
running an HTTP site a secure site we
could degrade you to some old version of
SSL that wasn't as effective that was
the ghost for nobility which was a
vulnerability in G let's see which is
the the fundamental library on Linux
computers it does everything from the
open command and syscall so node if you
open a file it's gonna call down into
this function and it's the foundation of
Linux and there's a vulnerability that
allowed anyone to remotely take over
your computer without any credentials on
it that was a big one you may never hear
about these things if you don't follow
that appropriate channels but if you
have all the right people on Twitter or
you subscribe to Microsoft's going to
really feed stuff like that you'll get
it right away
I'm stagefright that was that was
amazing I thought this is hilarious you
could send a message to someone's
Android phone and this is recently in
the last year and you could take over
their computer in order their phone and
root their phone I'm remotely and so I
mean I could just get in your phone do
some kind of message sending I will go
into the details and have your phone
it's mine at that point and that's where
we get things like the dying DNS and
twittering get up or down the other day
that's that was millions of cable boxes
that had network connections that
destroyed Twitter and github DNS
infrastructure or the infrastructure
they use so it's really important that
the people here the do IT web whatever
everything we put an IP address on
everything we connect to the Internet
has the power to take down the world's
biggest sites that people use for a lot
of important things I mean yes Twitter
sure it can go down but github people
deploy code off github health care
companies upload code off github I'm
it's just it's really a frightening
thing that we have all of this and of
course via flash and flash and flash and
flash and eventually we have WordPress
in WordPress
they're not bad things they just have
very big code bases and they're very
vulnerable this stuff the developers of
those platforms aren't bad people they
just have a lot to manage and that's why
it's important that we think about this
side so more WordPress so it's obviously
a hard problem it's it's a really really
hard problem
vulnerabilities can be everywhere so
this is a this is a not very beautiful
thing I made in draw the i/o which is
Google's old drawing thing that has the
layers of the tcp/ip model in the OSI
model which are the two networking
stacks the models represent those and
you can see all the protocols and
services within each layer I'm I've
highlighted in blue some of the more
important ones ones that you deal with
more often so who's in who in here is
used meteor before anybody meteor it's
it's a pretty cool framework DDP is the
way they communicate data that's in here
WebSockets his WebSockets and you've
probably use them if you don't even
think you have because it's like
underneath everything ASCII believe it
or not IRC SSL SSH all these protocols
are composed of millions of lines of
code in all of those have
vulnerabilities and because we talk over
things like HTTP we're dealing with all
the properties that HTTP has so it's
important to use things like SSL it's
important to do things like certificate
pinning where we have to make sure that
people can't reverse-engineer our apps
on our phones so that's the thing if you
have an SSL certificate on your iOS or
Android app and I can reverse engineer
that certificate and basically bypass
the fact that it's encrypted if you're
not doing certificate pinning which is a
way to disallow that I won't go into the
either and those are all important
things I've worked on consultant gigs
and stuff around like hey guys you
should be doing this pinning there's not
a direct line ability but it was really
easy for me to go in and just see what
you're talking to back to your server
and they're like nah we don't think it's
a big deal right now it's like okay you
can't fight them I mean you can try a
little bit but then they'll just fire
you
but there is hope and I don't know if I
have sound but Star Wars on cue epic
Star Wars music who's gonna see a rogue
one this December who saw the last stars
movie this December did you guys like it
is it good yeah ray was definitely my
favorite character out of all the movies
I mean I obviously was you know 10 years
like not alive when the first view came
out maybe longer but I watched all of
them I was a big fan and she was really
cool so yeah that was good that's a good
movie I hope you guys see the next one
so it's important that first we
understand that there's a problem and
secondly understand that there's a right
way to do this kind of stuff there's a
right way to approach security there
will help us build better applications
and not succumb to heartbleed and all
those other terrible things
so first way that's wrong is security
through obscurity and that's basically
when you keep your system safe because I
just don't know what it is how it works
they know nothing about it but I mean
they don't they're always gonna
something about it so that's not the
right way for that to work when you see
someone say we have unbreakable
cryptography unbreakable security that
is absolutely BS they do not there's no
such thing as perfect security if
someone says to buy my product for 50
million dollars that we will secure your
websites with the best encryption known
to man if they don't publish their
source code then you know don't don't
buy them that's ridiculous and if you
ask any photographer that's waste parter
than me about mathematical properties
and crypto they'll always tell you
there's a way to get around it and if if
you've spent long up looking at it I
mean yes maybe one day when plum
computers come out we'll find a better
way but who knows that day is not right
now
so I I don't know if this is actually a
specific one but I like to I I came up
with it and someone else probably came
up with it but basically you just
completely ignored that security is a
problem and you just go about your jolly
day and forget about it so yeah that's
not that's also not good and it really
sucks I'm telling you it really sucks to
think about security sometimes because
we just want to build better
functionality build features build a
better UI all that kind of stuff
it will save you a lot no I'll show you
I mean I think I've already showed you
that we have honour abilities and they
exist I'm going with the assumption that
you guys know that people can act all
the time and this is important so I'm
here to tell you about how you can
actually do it pretty easily so I think
this is this is my opinion the preakness
of the community is doing it this way so
security by design is when you design it
from the ground up as you build a ha
plication from the phase of prototyping
at a lesser amount but from the phrase
of prototyping is actually production
deploying to the design to be secured so
that means thinking about security in
the sense ok when it actually gets the
play production I need to keep I need to
have a ship yes I need to not show
identifying information so not have
these headers that tell you that your
backends and PHP or know they're
expressed or whatever which do exist and
are off and on by default
I'm keeping things like that in mind
acknowledging the various can occur in
code we all know that happens and some
of us here may have been affected who
here has had their I don't want to
disclose this but if you want to who
here is how the company that's been
affected by a breach before yeah so it's
a non-negligible people and how many
people really really or how many people
here dealt with the you know the QA team
coming in operation seems thing like fix
this or fix that anybody so nobody had
the work of the dev team or the security
team there like fix the vulnerabilities
after they discovered them a little bit
okay
yes so that's that's that's one thing is
that when things are discovered there's
this constant dynamic between the dev
team and often the security team we're
like hey I found this problem go fix it
and if they do that's great if they
don't then you just deal with it and now
is the big thing we dealt with that
cisco is that the company has 172
thousand employees in the like nine of
the 12 route routers in the internet the
switches are on cisco hardware so over
was that three-quarters of the internet
runs on cisco hardware and we were
responsible for breaking into our own
products before the bad guys dead and so
if we found something we disclosed it
through the internal system and those
teams would fix it we would hope they
fixed it and cisco is great i had a very
security culture so that was stressed
and but if you're in a smaller company
and the people above you or I mean below
you whatever don't think that security
is important and but you're telling them
to fix things and then that's obviously
an issue and we'll get into a little bit
about that later
so again maintaining prioritizing a
security team either it's just one
person is a good thing to do I mean
thinking about how attackers will try to
hurt you
so that's great let's let's let's make
sure I'm focus on this so the next thing
is understanding the enemy and yourself
I had it really not so insightful quote
by son Zhu here I figured I take it out
and but basically you've got these two
opposing parties and you think of like
black hat and white hat hackers and so
this is from an old comic I I it comes
up all the time you you look at black
hat stuff it's probably from something
you guys know more yeah III mean about
the extent to which cartoons I watch was
like Tom and Jerry and even that was
kind of like before my time and so I'm
not pretty young so winter hats whatever
black hats and white hat so your black
hats white hats gray hats what's all
that mean so they're used to classify
hackers by the motivations purpose
compensation whatever and again the term
hacker is like really miss it's using
all different ends of ways we're now
referred to refer to as security when I
run the hackathon re first was students
or people that want to come and build
stuff that wasn't there before can be
anything but in this case we're talking
about people who do some kind of
security okay
so motivation who cares it's really
helpful to understand the motivation
that attackers have and that all the
defenders have when they go about
building systems an attacker is going to
attack them it could be money powered
destruction for the bad guys often for
the good guys it's morality
responsibility and protection of the
users that they're going to try and save
and not lose the information some of
these things there's a gray area in
between some people are different
so why ATS are the people and you think
of anything of NCIS because you can type
on the keyboard two people are gonna
talk from the keyboard at the same time
we learn that from this
so this this is this is what I do when I
go to a bridge this is exactly what I
did what you hackers are security
researchers practice responsible
disclosure which is when you disclose it
without actually publicly disclosing it
first you give it to the company bug
Bonnie's Facebook gave out like 14
million dollars last year it's either 4
or 14 a lot in bug bounties they spread
security awareness go back and tell your
companies hey security is a problem
let's think about it more that's at
least do a check in our build tool or
our tests that test these properties and
they also maintain active Twitter
accounts please if you ever want to
follow security people the good guys are
often always on Twitter the bad guys are
on there too
but the good guys the anonymous hacker
is that whole group they often like to
screw around and just completely Dass
their accounts and do stuff like that
but the good guys do have Twitter
accounts so follow them don't follow me
I don't I I I'm now stuck in this place
where I like JavaScript and I like
security and now if I tweet anything
about JavaScript the security people can
unfollow me if I tweet anything about
security the JavaScript people are
following me so I'm stuck in this weird
place but there are way better people
black hats this is probably one of my
favorite movies of all time it's hackers
from 1995
so this is where hackers in the back end
the bad guys they are hacking the Gibson
witches in this this movie and obviously
there are these like white old like
neckbeard II dude it's like no no no no
no like blackhat hackers can be anybody
who knows like it can be in being a cat
I all know can be a dog and they can be
your mom so just be aware that black
hackers do this if you ever see a room
with a bunch of neon lights it's
probably bad guys that's from 1985
so black hats motivations are usually
money which like the LinkedIn data
breach they stole other credentials
power North Korea and Sony you can
arguably say that was for power on
destruction the Ukrainian power grid
were just knocked out a few months ago I
mean that's a bad thing the US electric
grid is in a terrible state we spend
billions on research in the country
working on that
labs in my university and others I'm
revenge hacktivists the people find me
people that like to screw around this
stuff just because they're doing it for
the greater good um there depends they
can be good or bad um so what's a
vulnerability it's when you make an
application do something that's not
supposed to do and define them you have
to understand your application and
that's great for us developers those of
us that can write code
you're already lightyears ahead of
security operations people they've never
written code before if you ever go and
interview for a security job a lot of
times they'll ask you hey do you know
how to write code and if you do that's
good because when you think about it if
you know if you are pen testing a
sighted pen testing is penetration
testing when you try and go hack in the
you know some website or product and
then disclose vulnerabilities if you
know that this foreign feel this
password login field how its implemented
or can think about how it's implemented
then you know what to target so you know
it might not really be a great idea to
go into the browser inspector and change
the background color of the pages CSS to
blue because that's not going to do
anything I mean why would that do
anything but you might start trying to
fuzz or inject a lot of data into the
password field and keep clicking submit
until you see if you can find something
so it's good to be ware wary of how
things are implemented so it's good to
know the application so thinking about
the functionality the intended behavior
so whether it's important to think
intended functionality and it's ended
behavior which is application used as an
input this is the biggest one and what
does that vacation produces output so
thinking of these things are the most
important things to think about when
you're looking application to see if it
has some sort of owner ability and I'll
have all these slides online later so no
worries um so it's here's an example
Wikipedia versus CNN suppose that you
find and authenticated that
authenticated regular users can edit
page content so is it a vulnerability if
you think it's a vulnerability in
Wikipedia raise your hand we're not
seeing that anybody yes I think it'd be
bad if we found that I'm not going to
get political if some CNN posted an
article about cats and it's someone
edited that to say that the cats are now
president and they're taking over the
country we probably say that's a
vulnerable
I'm Wikipedia obviously if you're
authenticated you can go and change
content because that's how video works
so it's good to think of things in the
context of how they work attacking is a
process so this step one is almost
always reconnaissance investigating it
investigating the head resists are sent
up the code itself on the client that's
looking at the state that's maintained
the local storage your cookies all of
those things and the flags in the
cookies all stuff like that um two is
develop of our nobility hypothesis and
this will be repeated over and over
thinking that hey I got this form field
maybe I can inject it with something
maybe I can do something with it I'm
three is that test that four is to
develop an exploit assuming you find
that your tests work that kind of
formalize it and distribute the code to
the company and say hey I found this
problem with this code base or your boss
whatever and then sup fives profit get
swag or protect the world and your
mileage may vary on that so bug bounties
often do like swag and/or money or
whatever Google SCAP is like 40 grand
for Android remote code execution
vulnerabilities so if you find a way to
hack in the Android phone without being
authenticated and unreal like mine code
on it then you they'll give you up to
40k in taxing does apply so somebody
United calm just opened up a bug bounty
program I'm in a Georgia Tech student
found 20 low to mid level
vulnerabilities not very big ones I mean
he got about 300k worth of airline miles
or so it was like it was like 100
million miles or 10 million or something
ridiculous and the government just came
to him the other day it's like hey you
gotta pay taxes on that now so so yeah
so a student you know has to come up
with taxes for a 300 K of stuff so
hopefully they can just take some miles
but yeah you can get cool stuff by doing
this so you can see this is very much
like it's almost like this scientific on
the scientific process of thinking about
experiment I'm how do I test it and then
how do I actually formalize it and then
how do I go and get it to the people
this last step is more the disclosing of
the thing or using it to like take it
over the world or
like that okay I'm so injection back to
is it's a it's important to understand
all the input to the application like I
said foreign fields are just one but we
have a lot query perimeters URL path
post parameters cookies Heather's
follow-up loads functionality emails
form fields WebSockets local browser
storage there is so much here anything
where you can get input into the
application and back to the backend or
the client depending how much logic you
exposing the client that's a potential
attack factor that you're going to be
thinking about these things we design
your app because you want to think how
do I protect this how do I validate the
input how do I do rate limiting things
like that so you have to understand data
flow to so it's important to understand
if data goes from like X to Y what is it
going through and how is it getting
there and what are the things that's
affecting along the way I mean how does
the output of the page flow through the
program so if you make a new Facebook
post in the post on the newsfeed it
displays but also in your timeline make
something new is there a vulnerability
whereby posting in the newsfeed
something won't show up but then when
someone likes it and it shows up on
their feed but it runs some malicious
script that you hid in the post and then
they are now taking over from their
account which does happen and it has
happened before at Facebook and other
places so now I'll actually talk about
JavaScript and what it means to write
secure code in JavaScript and it the
modules you might want to look into and
the process that kind of stuff so this
is like my favorite Jeff I don't know if
it's real doesn't even know if it's real
raise your hand if you think it's real I
mean it's like there's there's there's I
there's like a really I don't know it's
that's great I love that okay so I'm
gonna have a little legend of what is a
home showing stuff so I'll have a yellow
box and link to software software is now
a top-level domain whoever came up with
the idea that dot coffee and dot
software and all this other like crap
should be tough little domains that is
awful didn't never do that that's like
why like I don't know when I when I got
my first domain I couldn't find a jarred
smith.com because you know it turns out
Jerry Smith comm is also someone that
does development
and also the security so I was like
great you know that was the best name to
have so I did Jared - Smith - or - Smith
net because my friend told me that Don
net was the best domain name okay cool
let's say that hopefully he watches this
so yeah that'll be that's kind of a
little show so the first one really look
at command injection so it's when
untrusted data is sent to an interpreter
of some kind whether it be SQL in eval
statement JavaScript
it doesn't matter something that
interprets input as part of a command or
query and so it's the injection
malicious code in the programmer logic
like I said through SQL no SQL evals OS
instructions you know like an open file
in the system if you can get data across
SSH and have it run and open and do some
weird stuff that's also that LDAP has a
lot of injection when you do security
for awhile you'll realize that Windows
is just a treasure trove of
vulnerabilities it's so much fun to pen
test it's it's a blast but you know Mac
is not really like it used to be the
thing and you would have if you didn't
want to get a virus but now that happens
all the time so I don't think anything
is safe anymore and we also have
refrigerators dossing people's Twitter
accounts and sites oh nothing I go to
the low cent talk after this they're
giving a talk on hardware hardware
workshop and they do IT and I talked to
one of their guys about this stuff and
they think security is important which i
think is great so that's good good for
them so command injection so how do they
combat that you want to validate all you
use that input on the server side
not just the client side it's great to
do it in the client but also you have to
do it in the server before you throw it
to any interpreter don't use eval I know
who uses eval but set timeout uses email
set interval function new function that
uses eval underneath everything that
goes into these needs to be sanitized
honestly everything you do needs to be
sanitized and then I found this really
cool library called Express validator
it's got a significant stars on github
everything I'd post has some it's been
updated within the last a year at least
most of them in the last few days and
with some of that trash
obviously you can validate yourself too
but this kind of adds some nice stuff
right so cross-site scripting this one
is a blast this one I really love
cross-site scripting so you can
basically run malicious JavaScript in
the victims browser in the target
application so successful XSS can steal
user information cookies session IDs
redirecting malicious websites download
malware act on these errs behalf it goes
on and on and on so mark zuckerberg a
few years ago he was hacked by this guy
when he told Facebook that there was a
XSS vulnerability and they didn't
respond they didn't handle it very well
and so he's like great you know the best
idea the best thing I could possibly do
here and I found that vulnerability I
can get like you know thousands of
dollars done it's a good at the CEO of
the company and take over his account
that's the best idea so you did that and
I don't know what they did to him but
they definitely did not give him the
money so that was like success there's
plenty of other examples it's basically
with XSS you are able to post you know
think of it like a snippet feel if
there's a site that takes code snippets
imagine if that codes in that field
would let you put a script tag in it and
then when that gets displayed in a new
page that script tag will load the user
won't see it in imagine that script
field is not instead of alert even
hacked because it's the worst thing to
do
it's instead xmlhttprequest because
that's an everything document dot cookie
to George Smith comm slash command and
control server and now I have your
cookie I'm good my browser use a nifty
Chrome extension login as you and start
tweeting you know bad things about
yourself so that's as easy that is and
it's the only thing that will prevent
that right now is sanitizing your inputs
there are efforts to do automatic
content contextual sanitization and I
was thought it was my senior design
project we essentially were able to
rewrite parts of the PHP interpreter
using an extension and modify all input
as it comes into the application on the
fly with less than 2% overhead and
sanitize any input coming from the user
based on the context um it works with p
3 5 & 7 but obviously no one's gonna use
it because they don't install an
extension that's real
hard it really sucks so they're not
going to do that but there's other
things angular has a built in context
conceptual it's escaping Django does it
by default and so things are starting to
pick up on that
so again validate sanitize all user and
put in code output it's really like if
you have a Civet field and you can put
HTML there and it's not supposed to be
there and then the next page shows HTML
you can get rid of that just by encoding
those those HTML tags if you at least
just escape the script less than greater
then you'll be much better set
appropriate hazards I'll show you
essentially a second little set things
that browsers now recognize how prevent
XSS more automatically a chrome also has
XSS auditor which filters at some amount
of XSS and I'm not really going in depth
until a lot of this if you do go to some
of the resources at the end and look in
the more this web security stuff there's
lots of different classes of XSS and
things like that so validation again you
can use that library and setting
appropriate hazards this helmet library
is great I saw someone with a react
library that was helmet as well um this
is different this let's use all kinds of
headers and your things like secure
cookies and all kinds of stuff like that
please use it it's simple it's an
Express app it's like five lines okay
weird a cross-site request forgery
that's that this is kind of complicated
but it's an extension of XSS where you
can basically frame on top of someone's
browser you can essentially what you're
doing is making them click on the site
underneath your page that they already
have loaded in the background so if you
have you know Jared Smith or Jared
Michael Smith comm slash blog and
they're on my blog I can put a window of
Facebook behind it it's invisible and if
they are authenticated at Facebook
already and Facebook has a cross-site
scripting vulnerability then I can make
them click on post or like sin or you
know send me money a bank is a good
example is I can put their bank behind
that and make them send money to me when
they only think they're on my blog and
that happens that happens all the time
and it's really not an uncommon thing
all of these things happen a lot and
these are things that can be prevented
by validating input
that attackers usually starts target
state changing requested for nuance of
the way it works you have to target
request that you can predict if you can
randomize requests in a way that they
can't duplicate it then this can't
happen and so the way to deal with that
is just include a random unpredictable
token request and an ad tokens request
which mutates state in this sea surf
library is super popular and does it for
you an express you will be vulnerable to
CSRF if you have not success honorably
if you don't use sea surf all it does is
add a nonce which is a random token to
your request no overhead and it just
validates it I mean I send no overhead
it's completely negligible and that will
prevent CSRF because then you can't
essentially make them send requests on
your behalf because they can't predict
what that request will be session
management please please please please
don't implement your own authentication
mechanism people that bill ooofff and
all of those things did it and spent
years doing it because frankly they're a
lot smarter than me and probably smarter
than most of us they know what they're
doing they've dealt with authentication
for a long time
so again developers often do implement
their own authentication I hope you guys
don't but just don't do that so session
management is hard I mean it's cookies
being stolen stuff like that um don't
expose the session token' URL a few
years ago actually a long time ago
there's a guy named I can't remember his
name
he's a bunch of documentaries and he
basically found one really where AT&T
had the user tokens they identified them
as the URL so /url
and they were iterable so it was like /
1 / 2 / 3 / 4 and you could get to their
page with a credit card info right there
by doing that I mean he made a big deal
about it he told the whole world but
without something like unity or maybe
you told them first whatever he went to
jail and I can't renew his name he's a
he's are actually pretty terrible person
he's not very nice session tokens should
timeout make them timeout don't have
such tokens live for years it's a
terrible idea and recreate them after
successful login this is the standard
practice always we create the math you
log in and use hu HTTP for sending
tokens and appropriate permissions and
also use OAuth 2.0 or sam'l or some
appropriate authentication
some throw our libraries and JavaScript
that will do this permissions you can do
that in passport that's wasn't get to
that's a very simple authentication
library that does open all that it's
very very popular and Express uses a
bunch of you might already use it I mean
this permissions library makes citing
permission it's easy if I having to
write your own logic password management
they're often handled incorrectly um you
can't just leave your passwords in plain
text on your database obviously you
obviously can't or you can't encrypt
them either because if someone steals
the key they can just decrypt this so
why are you encrypting it that's the
that's the point you can't just encrypt
it you have to also you have to hash it
but if you hash it with algorithms that
are you know 15 years old like sha-1
then I can crack it with my laptop in
like less than a second um so you need
to use good hashes you also need to use
salts which are essentially random
tokens appended to the end that add
additional protection I'm so an example
is the 2012 LinkedIn breach passwords
are hash but failed uses salt so when
they failed uses a salt you can look up
things called rainbow tables which is a
mapping of hashes to passwords or since
it's basically that I mean then you can
crack the passwords more quicker and
there's tools already do this stuff if
you look up John the Ripper or a hash
cat they use GPUs and do it in no time
so use be critique ripped is the
standard hashing algorithm it's
developed and approved by cryptographers
it's open source I'm in for strong
passwords too and also please aware 2016
that people use two-factor off I mean
like why have you not been doing that if
you can prefer the TTP which are the
one-time passwords or u2f which is the
great and Fido you bikies it's a these
things right here if you see those they
get hugged lets you to use that Google
if you use it use Google Authenticator
for the one-time passwords or of--they
if you have to you can also use SMS and
but the thing is these days ATT and rise
all those companies do a terrible job of
validating and signing your text someone
can't spoof your text and log into your
Twitter account with a phone that's not
yours but can make a PT or Twitter think
it's your phone um that's the thing it
does happen I'm so having passwords with
bcrypt that's the node B crypt
implementation it's other places as well
I'm two factor auth this line right it's
kind of all
I'm really surprised that two-factor
authors not really well-maintained right
now maybe people just implement
themselves but yeah you can use the SDKs
cookies go a little bit faster on if the
set cookies using the following Flags
secure HP only let them be only access
of HTTPS in JavaScript it should be only
means that you can't do that XML HTTP
requests talking about cookie because
then it can't be accessed there's other
ways to actually do it properly scoping
is when you can do things that only lets
hookie be accessed by your domain on
your own website so that means that CSRF
from another site can't happen so
there's some permissions right there a
cookie session is a wrap from cookies
those are pretty good packages and the
key group is the cool library for
signing and verifying that cookies are
the same do still exist strict mode I
mean you may hate strict mode but it's
really great please use it on prevent
silent errors from happening helps the
JavaScript and also perform
optimizations you'll have to use it
doesn't prevent all types of our
abilities that really doesn't prevent
anything explicitly security but it
helps errors not fail silently
information disclosure that can be a bad
thing as well when you accidentally show
the users or people using application
too much information about it so stuff
like the ex powered by Express Heather
you don't disable those things often
they're disabled by default but if they
are enabled you should disable them
since the data exposure please don't
expose people's data
don't let your whole entire States voter
registration database just be sitting on
the public internet Georgia did that and
everyone in the entire state lost all of
their information social security cards
and everything how it's like last year
and don't break users trust use SSL
HTTPS it's again it's 2016 we should see
a green shield and your browser free
don't that's a that please do that who
is not using HTTPS in their production
app I mean okay I don't I know you
wouldn't raise your hand I know everyone
still I mean we have to talk more if you
are encrypt data at rest in transit
disable caching forms often that stuff
gets sort of local storage which can be
accessed by XSS let's encrypt
free SSL Certificates why are we not
doing it they're free and they're in
every single browser you already use
some useful tools there's something
called reads hired j/s that would scan
your packages for vulnerabilities
automatically you can do it in your npm
build scripts note security platform is
super great is that they had like
yesterday or one of these was that this
is recent it's still being used it just
adds to NPM SEO lie and you'll do live
automate security tests automated tests
are better than no test the best thing
is doing security audits of your
platform docker is great shrink wrap is
good so takeaways this is the last thing
I talked about takeaways acknowledge the
security is worth spending time on you
can see that this is a problem people
deal with this we don't want this to
happen I don't you guys will use our
information and I don't want you to come
back and tell your boss that I taught
you something you didn't implement it
and you come and blame me and sue me for
what I did and didn't tell you
understand applications to get a
high-level I gave you some tools to do
that just keep if you want to learn more
read about it I'll have resources at the
end of this that you can get them from
the slides later I'm have the mindset an
attacker when building and testing your
systems
think about not just how it's developed
how you're developing it but how similar
ways Hacket that helps you enforce
better properties in the new security
best practices that's all the thing I
told you there's a lot more to there
there's a lot more security stuff I gave
you some the highest the biggest ones
and finally go back to your companies
and tell them that security is important
so again if you spend more money and
coffee than IT security will be hacked
you deserve to be hacked so that's this
great clip like that
so I mean you will be hacked all right
thank you if you have questions come see
me afterwards you can reach me in all
those places thank you
[Applause]